let's read this first story from the
daily mail biden stands by his comment
that putin cannot remain in power but
insists he was expressing moral outrage
not policy change claims three russia
gaffes didn't happen despite white house
having to walk them back
i i got to show you the video everybody
we nee you need to watch this because um
i'm sitting i'm sitting downstairs
i i get a message it's from cassandra
fairbanks mcdonald and she's like you
need to watch this video no no like no
laughing and lol anything was like watch
this and then i watch it and we're just
playing it on the counter and then all
of a sudden we get to this point where
everyone in the room busts out laughing
and i'm just like we are screwed come on
man let me let me let me play this clip
for you guys and then we'll we'll
all wait let me fix the audio for you
but you know it's funny because before
the show started i was browsing twitter
i didn't get a chance to do that today
it's very necessary and i saw your tweet
with that biden video and i was cracking
up i didn't want to interrupt your
conversation there oh i was like we are
screwed yeah all right let's see if we
got it hopefully it's loud enough are
you worried that other leaders in the
world are going to start to doubt that
america is back if some of these big
things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what's getting walked back it made it
sound like just in the last couple days
uh it sounded like you told us troops
they were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about
helping train the troops in that are the
the ukrainian troops that are in poland
that's with the context i sat there with
those guys for a couple hours that's
what we talked about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with
beating with and talking with the
ukrainian troops or in poland and when
you said a chemical weapon
used by russia would trigger a response
in time
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
what the world wants to know the world
wants to know a lot of things i'm not
telling them what the response would be
then russia knows the response
that was amazing also i want to say i
just love how it starts with this
reporter talking to him like he's five
years old it's like the exact cadence
and tone of voice you used to speak to a
child with god bless peter ducey he's
been great this entire uh regime so far
he's going to be really important next
couple years too yeah it's it's crazy
how
the guy from fox news is the only one
questioning the president look if if you
know when you have a president trump
you get a journalist who's like trump i
got to push back i want to answer i want
some questions answered i'll be like you
know we should have journalists pushing
back no matter what it is
if you know trump could come out and
give a good answer and a journalist is
like i'm going to push back and i want
you to answer these these concerns i'm
fine with that but what did we get under
trump
every single journalist was just always
spitting and yelling and complaining and
very very unserious lies manipulations
chasing false stories now we get biden
arguably one of the worst presidents
we've ever had
who said
when you're there you're going to see
people in front of a damn tank refusing
to move it's like what does that mean
like troops are going to be there he
said if russia's chemical weapons will
respond in kind uh
is the u.s going to use chemical weapons
in ukraine well remember tim the adults
are back in charge that's what we heard
for four years we need to get the adults
back in charge and uh this is the best
that they have to offer i think yeah i
think we went too far to the upper
limits with that whole adult thing yeah
i said i could have been a little
younger my favorite don junior post was
he says you're supposed to eat your
vegetables not elect them oh my gosh
and so that's what we have that right
here i mean he's completely lost it and
you know to your point
the media was so uh you know vicious
towards trump
and they would lie about him but now
they cover for their lies and they'll
actually run stories about how joe biden
didn't actually say what he said this is
what he actually meant and so it's a
total double standard and it's complete
bs we saw lindsey graham
call for the assassination of vladimir
putin and i was like yo i call him lady
g uh so there was a report a couple
years back about lindsey graham lady g
about how he had relationships with a
bunch of men
and the establishment would say alex you
can't call lindsey graham lady g it's
going to be hard for us to recommend
senators to work with you and that's
okay so i doubled down on lady g and so
lindy he's
is he drunk when he goes on hannity
calling for the assassination it's the
same thing here and so uh it's
who's running the messaging of this it's
it's so i bring him up because now biden
is saying you know what what did he said
quote for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power
and i'm just like
wow
you want to talk about no peace
no chance any kind of resolution here
you can thank lindsey graham and then
you can thank the president because
yo
vladir putin's going to be like okay
there is absolutely no reason to
communicate at all with the americans
yeah we know their position so that you
know i'm not a military expert by any
means okay but uh i've been in a few
fights in my life or have seen some
fights happening and i think the number
one goal should be to de-escalate right
and the adults in charge currently have
no interest in de-escalating why because
the people who fund their campaigns and
fund their livelihoods uh something
called the military industrial complex
and say no de-escalation you guys are
pushing for war we're sending in the
migs and like i said nobody knows what
the hell a mig is but everybody's
sending in tweets in all caps sending
the migs and so i don't want to send in
the migs i want to send in the piece
yeah it's hilarious uh you know the
adults who are in charge completely fail
to understand that there is a concrete
world that exists outside of their
rhetoric and politics doesn't just exist
on twitter or on television and the
things they say to foreign leaders or
about leaders are actually going to have
consequences beyond their constituents
liking them more or throwing red meat to
their fan base or the right people
disliking them i mean calling for the
assassination of a foreign leader online
while they're invading another country
and tensions are as high between us and
them as they've ever been or for the
president of the united states to say
that the leader of a nuclear power needs
to be removed from his position is so
unbelievably out of line and insane and
irresponsible but of course they're the
grown-ups right and we constantly heard
about how trump had mean tweets and
trump wasn't responsible with the things
that he said but you know what things
were somewhat together at that point and
these people are literally not at all
different except
trump's policies were actually somewhat
effective
i like how trump would you know they
accused him of
working with dictators
and i'm just like if it brought peace
it was i can't remember who who it was i
don't want to quote the wrong person but
he was like you got to understand the
reason putin didn't invade ukraine under
trump was because trump was doing his
bidding right what the hell does that
even mean it's so stupid i'm like
pulling how does that make sense
afghanistan i guess pulling our troops
out of syria okay i guess like so what
you're saying is donald trump was
de-escalating war and crushing isis so
putin was like all right i'm a chill
yeah should he not have done that i mean
we should i guess if it makes putin
happy we shouldn't do it but this is why
it was a perfect and beautiful life i
got it what is it if we really want to
piss off putin then we just need to to
stand back while isis comes back
that'll show that that russian that's
true
so i've been doing a lot to to you know
support ukraine i've banned moscow meals
in my home
i'm not doing white russians anymore uh
in fact i'm just going to dump out every
bala vodka i own
and if you're not doing stuff to help
ukraine each day you have to check
yourself before you wreck yourself uh
because ukraine is like my total
everything now can i ask you something
um what's your policy on cats that were
bred in russia competing in cat shows
yeah i want to make sure you really have
a sufficiently tough response to their
aggressiveness yeah i don't think that
should be allowed you know we can't take
serious measures we should ban russian
cats from america yeah okay i went to a
yogurt restaurant like a frozen yogurt
place and they had a chalkboard when you
walked in and someone drew the ukrainian
flag on it and i'm like the people
working here are like 16 years old and i
i don't think anything i i don't i don't
think any of them know where nowhere
ukraine is no they couldn't they
couldn't point it out if there was uh
the letter u and a picture of a crane
next to it on a map that's right
pointing right to these i love all the
buildings lit up in like blue and yellow
and i wish people paid this much
attention to ukraine in october of 2020
when it was reported that hunter biden
was getting paid big money by barista
but uh now everybody's ukraine expert
ukraine stan adam kinzinger is you know
fawning over zielinski shirtless every
day on twitter um
if you came to me and you were like joe
biden actually has a gigantic mind
control device and the reason he always
seems out of internet is because he he's
like professor x and he just exhausted
himself and his mind controlling people
into believing fake news i'd be like
well
you know
there's been so many fake stories and
people keep believing it that almost
sounds like a plausible explanation
biden's got a mind control device
because i don't i don't understand how
you can have millions of people in this
country
like one day all of their all their
twitter accounts have blue hats then all
their twitter accounts have syringes
then all their twitter accounts have
ukraine flags yeah and like no matter
how many fake stories come out they just
like yeah i'm gonna go along with
whatever whatever they say or like it
was it bill burr when he's talking to
joe and he was like i just turned on the
news once every two weeks and do they
tell me to do yeah i'm like man oh boy
is that
someone's got to have mind control
powers i swear thinking's hard it's it's
hard to think and people
have whatever the hell they got going on
they're fantasy football leagues that
they got to pay attention to or they
have their netflix series they really
tuned into doing the real critical
thinking about the important issues it's
hard they just want to you know listen
to the experts right and the experts are
bought and paid for unfortunately by
people who
don't want to do the right thing how
many how many days do you think it'll be
until some you know fact checker
publishes an article saying tim poole
claims joe biden has mind control powers
yeah one day
yeah yeah yeah two can absolutely see it
be like in tim pool insanely claims joe
biden has mind control powers because
they don't know what sarcasm or joke is
or
or if they're really meta they'll
release an article saying tim poole
falsely claims we're going to release an
article about him making false claims
about joe biden's mind control power
you're onto something there seamus thank
you thank you so the whole well one
thing i wanted to mention here is when
we look at the scenario when we look at
the fact that trump was called a
puppet for putin every single time he
did something that russia might at the
very least appreciate or which wasn't um
you know explicitly aggressive towards
them we were told he was a puppet
this is exactly why russia gate was the
perfect lie for the deep state in the
industrial military complex to fabricate
about a sitting president of the united
states because they've been trying to
push for war with russia for years now
and all you have to say is well the
current president is being controlled
and anytime he doesn't want to go to war
with them anytime doesn't want to do
anything that would lead to war with
them it's because he's a puppet it's
because he's weak thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you